[موسيقى]
ضمن فعاليات اسبوع الازياء الفارسي قدم
مافيا ويليامز مصمم للازياء مجموعته
الجديده للخريف والشتاء المقبلين مجموعه
اعاد مصممها الامريكي البحث في ارشيف
للابداع في عرض مجموعته مفهوم جديد
الاناقه اطلالات برؤيه معاصره واستكشاف
لانماط من منظور مختلف معايير الرقي من
منظور معاصر لاعاده احياء التصاميم
الكلاسيكيه بحله متجدده تواكب متطلبات
النساء في زمننا هذا
[موسيقى]
الله
تعود القصات والتفاصيل القديمه بحله ترضي
ذوق الجيل الشاب احجام كبيره وقصات مفصله
مع الاكتاف البارزه والخصر الضيق والمريح
في الوقت عينه صممت المعاطف السوداء
المصنوعه في مشغل جيفونشي من اقمشه الستان
والكشمير والمهر وازدانت بطيات مقلوبه عند
الخلف او بازرار عند الخصر جاكيتات
البدلات المصممه مع طبقات شفافه بدات اشبه
بتجسيد المعاصر للفستان القصير مثل
السراويل الباقي الرياضيه الفاخره
والبلوزات المصنوعه من الجيرسي الناعم
والتصاميم الكارجو والملابس المزوده
باشرطه والتنانير الكلتيه والتنانير
العاديه المصنوعه من الفينتا او الصوف
اصدارت احدى القطع بنمط ازهار من
ارشيفونشي لتعود بحله متجدده من النايلون
المعالج بالليزر مع صباغه مفرطه
[موسيقى]
استطاع المصمم الامريكي ماتري ويليامز من
خلال هذا العرض ان يجمع بينما استوحى من
تصاميم معماريه هندسيه في بلده الام هناك
في امريكا
وتقديم مجموعه تناسب اجيال مختلفه من
النساء من عرض ازياء في باريس